it looks like the aftermath of a
detonation and in a way it is the bush
fires have created entirely new weather
systems with lightning and tornadoes
this is what laid beneath a pitched
battle against the fire while the
weather conditions have improved as you
would have heard as reported from New
South Wales and Victoria there are still
many fires that are raging and and there
is a very significant firefighting
effort which is continuing today though
further south in bands Dale Victoria it
began to rain it felt like hope and so
did this truck after truck came from all
around the state to deliver animal feed
to the remote farms that have been
ravaged by far all volunteers and some
of them are victims of the fire
themselves determined to help others
look everybody's got together the
livestock I'd z the show I need to feed
many other organizations we've turned up
the words got out that we needed to be a
food and produce and whatnot and yeah
it's been absolutely overwhelming have
no time to think
defended me own house and Nicolson
Monday no it stayed up all night I Drive
to barking in the morning to check get
me farm mom and dad's places go on five
and all spices parents are gone
the convoy set off today's a chance for
recovery and this is an extraordinary
operation this is only the first few
trucks you can see them going off now
they're all volunteers some of them have
suffered a lot in the fire themselves
but they're on their way to help
devastated communities these animals
were evacuated to safety before the
fires now they're trying to get them
back home and here in Victoria at least
to get back to normal